CBS News legal analyst Ricky Kleman is
with us this morning good morning good
morning to read this entire article in
some of the accusations is difficult and
one of the accusers of Schneiderman says
what do you do if your abuser is the top
law enforcement official in the state is
that why these women haven't spoken out
until now
well it certainly appears that way these
stories are tragic horrific and we see
the hypocrisy involved in someone in his
role what is a woman to do if it's the
Attorney General of the state of New
York does she feel like she can go to
the police no does she feel like she can
go to a district attorney no where does
she go does she even think maybe I don't
even know if it enters her mind to go to
the US Attorney
everyone somehow is connected so at some
point you say I have no recourse except
to go public this is the one type of
case because it's so extraordinary that
the non filing of a police report is
totally explicable what happens if they
do file a police report now would that
affect the case well at this point
they've gone public and if they want to
continue to pursue any action they can
file a police report and the Manhattan
district attorney has opened an
investigation now right yes the
Manhattan district attorney has opened
an investigation into these underlying
charges he's got some difficulties
though because what you are dealing with
first of all is the fact that these
women went public does not necessarily
mean that they want to pursue a criminal
case even assuming they do when you look
at the law in the state of New York what
we find is that what has happened here
is probably more than likely almost
definitely considered misdemeanor sexual
assault
that's a 1-year statute of limitations
and a one-year penalty you could go back
to the old allegations and they could
help buffer up that one year but the
difficulty is to get to a second to get
up to as felony you would need a weapon
you would need someone in a protected
class like elderly or a child or depends
on the seriousness of the injury
ask you something apposite they accuse
Neider Minh of having subjected them to
non-consensual physical violence is
there a such thing as consensual
physical violence in the law I suppose
that you could consent that someone
could hit you
people have habits but nonetheless they
say that that his defense is a fantasy
of his own yeah he offered role-playing
as a defense I don't know any woman of
color that thinks being called a brown
slave is any kind of role-playing let
alone someone who is choked yeah and
feels that she really may lose
consciousness it is tragic yeah claim in
thanks